Good morning church family.
My name is Jimmy Quinn and I get to serve on staff here
and today, get to the privilege
of opening God's word with you all.
One of my responsibilities is to help set the meeting agenda
for our church family meeting
that's happening this afternoon.
And we'd love for you to come. You're invited to come.
It's more than a business meeting.
Uh, it's an opportunity to, to hear where we're headed
as a church, to enjoy being together as a family.
We don't get to do that very often,
so we want to enjoy each other.
And we're gonna hear stories about
what God is doing around us.
Like we heard from Donna and Austin, speaking of Donna
and Austin, uh, Thursday.
Uh, Tuesday is Veterans Day.
And so we want to honor men like Austin and women
and their families who have served
and are serving our country.
So church, can you help thank them for their service.
If you are new to HHBC
or you haven't been here in a while, we've been walking
through the book of f of Second Samuel,
and so we're nearing an end.
So if you have your Bibles, turn
to Second Samuel chapter 21.
So some scholars believe that, that this section
of Second Samuel is more of an appendix, a thematic summary,
but others view it as kind
of the next chronological step in David's life.
And so today we're gonna,
we're gonna take the latter approach, uh,
that it's just a chronological step in David's life, uh,
primarily because I think we see, uh,
or get the impression that it's near the end of his reign.
So before we dive in, just to kind of give us a, a refresher
of, of where we've been, where we're headed,
we've got our chart, um,
and we can see here where, where David's rise.
And then right in the middle, the tragic downfall
of his sin, uh, with Bathsheba.
And since then, it's just been this downhill trajectory.
And, uh, that last little section,
David's public troubles 20
through 24 is what we're talking about.
And there's consequences, both legal, national
and personal consequences.
And so, um, some of those with, uh, David, some
of those consequences that we've seen
and we'll see are family tragedies and, and murders
and sexual immorality happen, rebellion and constant strife.
Last week if you were here, you heard John, uh,
talk about God's mercy
and how it's greater than our past sins.
And if you are a believer in Christ,
he has saved us from our past sins, our present sins
and future sins, and has cleansed
us with the blood of Christ.
He mentioned Romans eight, one, where there is now,
therefore no condemnation for those in Christ Jesus.
And I'm gonna refer to that passage multiple times today
'cause it's such a beautiful hope filled verse.
But that brings us to chapter 21.
And here's our main point today, the consequences
of sin still stings.
I'd like to thank John for giving me this passage
to talk about your sins and their consequences.
I'm kidding. Um,
and so we do know that there are real consequences
for our sin on this side of eternity.
So before we begin, I want to, uh, share a story,
a personal story that as I was preparing, um, really
reminded me of, of sin
and consequences in my personal life growing up.
But before I do, I think we need to give a few,
or I need to give a few, uh, introductory statements.
One, sin is ugly. My sin is ugly.
Your sin is ugly. Our sin is ugly.
Okay, number two, uh,
this happened more than 20 years ago in my life.
Now I say that not
because I've graduated from sinning, that is not the case.
I say that because a sin still grips me today
and I still struggle with sin.
And sometimes my heart is even uglier now than it was then.
Unfortunately, number three, um,
this is not a, an example that should be followed.
So high schoolers, middle schoolers, college students,
this is not a good example.
Don't follow my steps and you'll see why.
And then the fourth thing is, remember
to give grace to sinners, right?
Amen. Thank you. All right.
So in my senior year of high school, my second semester,
I took a class called advanced physics.
Why? I don't know, I still don't know why
I took advanced physics,
but on day one, our teacher said, okay,
here's your syllabus, uh, for the semester.
Complete the odd number
of questions at the back of the chapters.
Do chapters one through 30.
And, uh, because you're advanced students,
you have the freedom to do that on your own time.
Great, that sounds awesome. Pretty easy assignment.
Well, as high school boys
or high school seniors, we also had the privilege of
of off-campus lunch.
So it just so happened
that the physics class was right after lunch.
And so let's just say class attendance
was not my strong suit or my buddy's strong suit.
So with about two weeks to go of the semester, my buddies
and I decided to have a study night
to start working on our 30 chapters of physics.
So we get to chapter one
and we realize something advanced physics is hard
and this isn't gonna go very well.
And so after night one, we got one chapter done.
Night two we're, we're getting the hang of it,
we be getting, we we're getting smart.
So we decide, hey, you do chapter two,
I'll do chapter three, bro, you got chapter four,
and then we'll just kind share answers.
Brilliant plan except for physics, you gotta, yeah,
it builds off of each other.
You can't really do chapter four if you don't know
what's going on in chapter two.
So after night two, we've got two chapters down
and our pace is not going well.
So desperate high school boys, we decided
to borrow the teacher's textbook and he didn't know it.
And it, uh, was awesome for a little bit.
We were knocking out chapters left
and right that first night until we got caught.
So I'd love to tell you that we turned in the textbook
and it was good and wasn't,
but we had access to a copying machine.
And so again, it gets bad to worse
and our cheating scandal gets worse
and worse that our teacher finally said, okay,
you've gotta take a test.
You gotta take a test. And what you make on the test is
what you get in the, in the class.
And let's just say my result was not very good.
And um, the decision to be lazy,
to choose fun over responsibility
and then to cheat about it had lasting effects on my
transcript and my college scholarships that I did have.
And so this is a small picture of a big truth.
Sin has consequences
and we'll see that play out in various ways in our text
in Second Samuel today.
So let me pray for us, Lord,
as we open up your word in, um, trying to understand
and grapple, um, what's going on,
but also, uh, understand um,
how you've called us to live as sons
and daughters, uh, to reflect your goodness
that we sang about to a lost world.
Let us be convicted of the sin.
Let us be a people who, who choose, uh, to chase
after you in all times.
And it's in your son's name that we pray. Amen.
Two Samuel 21 verse one.
It says, now, there was a famine in the days of David
for three years, year after year.
Okay, pause for a second.
Anytime we see famines in scripture,
it often represents God's judgment.
And that's what's happening here
because Saul's sin, which was breaking the covenant
with the gibeonites, God had brought famine upon the land.
So this was Saul's personal sin that had
national consequences pick back up.
And David sought the face of the Lord.
And the Lord said there is blood guilt on Saul
and on his house because he put the gibeonites to death.
So the king called the Gibeonites and and spoke to them.
Now, the gibbon knights were not of the people of Israel
but were of the remnant of the Amorites.
Although the people of Israel had sworn des spare them,
Saul has had sought to strike them down in his zeal
for the people of Israel.
And Judah, our first point today is
that our sin has consequences both
individually and corporately.
Think about it. There are countless biblical stories
where a character is sinned and then faced consequences.
Of course, we've been talking the last few weeks about
David's sin and the consequences that he's had.
But what about Moses? Moses, if you remember, in pride
and frustration, he struck the rock.
He disobeyed God. And what was his consequence?
He was kept out of the promised land. What about Manasses?
Do you guys know the story of Manasses?
He's considered one of the most evil kings in all of Israel.
He built, he rebuilt pagan altars
that his father had destroyed and he worshiped false gods.
He defiled the temple with these false gods.
He practiced divination, sorcery,
consulted mediums and spirits.
And even more so, he buried his own, he burned his own sons
as offerings to these pa and gods.
And so because of those sins, what happened?
Well, God declared judgment on the entire people of Judah
and they were then sentenced to exile
and under the captivity of Babylon.
So one man's sin cost the nation their conseque.
A consequence, probably the most recognizable sin in all
of scripture I think is in the garden.
When Adam and Eve sinned, they disobeyed God
and they brought the curse of sin to all humanity.
So what's going on here in two Samuel is
that Israel made a treaty,
made a promise to the Gibby knights.
We see that back in Joshua chapter nine.
Then when Saul, when he was in power, he attempted
to annihilate them from the face of the earth.
So because of that sin,
because of the breach of the covenant,
God was causing famine in the land.
Sin Saul sin had lingering effects on the entire nation.
I think that leads us to ask ourselves a couple questions.
One, what are the consequences of my sin? Right?
You sin so you, I think it's only natural to say,
what are my consequences?
And two, how has my sin affected others?
There is a difference between eternal consequences
and earthly consequences.
The ultimate, the eternal consequences of our sin is what?
It's death according to Romans 6 23.
For the wages of sin is death.
Isaiah 59 2 says this, it says,
but your iniquities have made a separation
between you and your God.
And your sins have hidden his face from you so
that he does not hear.
The eternal consequence
of our sin is separation from God and death.
That is the consequence of man's rebellion.
Just like sin entered the world through Adam
and Eve, though we also have a promise in Romans five 19
where for as by one man's disobedience,
the many were made sinners.
So by one man's obedience, which we know is Jesus Christ,
the many will be made righteous Scripture shares
with us about our earthly consequences of sin as well.
Listen to what Paul says in Ephesians four 18
and 19 about those who liken themselves to their old self
and they choose to indulge sin.
It says they're darkened in their understanding,
alienated from the life of God
because of the ignorance that is in them due
to the hardness of heart.
They've become callous
and they've given themselves up to sensuality,
to greedy things to practice every spiritual kind
or every kind of impurity.
They were greedy.
One of the more earthly consequences of sin is more sin.
And there's this insatiable lust for more.
And it's, it's, I want more. And you're doled.
Our consciousnesses are are dulled
and we're blind to spiritual truth.
At least I know that to be true in my own life that
that sin just gr grapples me.
And it just, it's like a snowball.
I often want what's more. I want more. I want a little more.
I want the bigger house. I want the newer phone.
And we know that contentment is a gift.
We scratch and sniff at sin and then we want a little more.
Then we get curious and we want a little more
and a little more, a little more.
And before we know it, we have an addiction.
This lust and greed for more according
to one Corinthians two causes us to be folly
to spiritual things.
One of the earthly consequences of sin is more sin.
When Jesus began his ministry in Mark, it says,
the time has come, the kingdom of God is near repent
and believe the good news.
What is that good news?
The good news is for God's so of the world
that he gave his one
and only son that so whosoever believes in him,
should not have or should ha, should not perish
but have eternal life.
Amen. The ultimate
and the most severe consequence of varsity in his death
and separation from God.
But God. But God, when we repent of our sin
and we believe that God gave us his son to pay the price
for our consequences, we are forgiven.
We've been made right with God.
We're no longer an outcast, but we're part of the family.
There's no longer an eternal punishment for our sin
because Christ has already paid it.
Yes, sin will still sting,
but Christ has removed that eternal penalty.
But the text warrants us to ask that second question,
how does my sin affect others?
So in one Corinthians five,
Paul's writing about sexual sin, sexual immorality.
And he says this, don't you know
that a little yeast leavens the whole batch of dough?
I love red. Gimme those carbs, right? Can I get in? Amen.
Amen. Thank you, thank you.
Our scones are top notch here,
but biscuits, pancakes, muffins, I'll take them all.
I don't, I'm not a baker, I don't know much about yeast.
But what Paul is saying here is
a little yeast soon permeates the whole batch of dough.
Meaning even small hidden sins, even sins
that you may not think are a big deal affect
you and affect this body.
It will always have a ripple outward.
Just like Saul, sins affected Israel.
Our sin affects the body of Christ.
I love scripture. Almost anywhere where you see a command,
it is followed up with a promise
and that's what's happens in Proverbs 28 13.
This verse is full of hope.
It says whoever conceals his transgressions will not
prosper, but he who confesses
and forsakes them will obtain mercy.
I'd like to take a little rabbit trail here
and talk about confessing sin when we sin.
If you're a believer in Christ, you should feel conviction.
You know that the things that you did
grieve the heart of God.
And when convicted according to this passage,
we should confess those sins confess to one another.
We should bring it to light. We should repent of it.
And when that happens, we're relieved from this bondage of
of shame and guilt.
Conviction comes from the Holy Spirit.
Shame and guilt though comes from the enemy.
However, as believers, if we choose to hide this
or conceal it, it says we will not
prosper at times.
If you're like me, I may regret my sin
but not confess it or repent of it, I may get caught
but not confess and repent.
And then when that happens,
we start believing the enemies lies that he's spouting at us
and we find ourselves similar to Adam
and Eve, isolated and ashamed.
Proverbs 20 18, 28 13,
whoever conceals his transgressions will not prosper,
but he who confesses and forsakes them will obtain mercy.
That's the invitation today, confession and mercy 'cause
because when we conceal sin, it does several things to us.
It de desensitizes our consciousness.
It distorts relationships among each other.
You know we have Romans, it's all about one and others, but,
but it distorts that sin distorts those relationships.
It limits our effectiveness in gospel ministry.
It opens the door for the enemy
and it grieves the heart of God.
If you're here last week, John read Romans eight one.
This verse is full of
so much hope there is there now no condemnation
for those in Christ Jesus.
For the law of the spirit
of life has set you free in Christ Jesus.
From the law of sin
and death that my friends is the good news.
When conviction happens,
this good news does not mean though
that God will overlook our sins or our little faults
or our lapses or our little lies
or are cheating on physics tests or cheating on our taxes
or getting soda when you ordered water
or secretly looking at pornography here
or pornography there like those sins we think
aren't a big deal.
But in Romans it tells us that all sin breaks the heart
of God, breaks our fellowship.
Paul tells us also in Romans that just
because we have a forgiving God by no means, it says
by no means many times by no means should we take advantage
of his grace and of his mercy.
The problem is sin is sin big or small.
And though God loves us, his holiness is such
that he will not, he will not tolerate any kind
of sin in any kind of evil.
There must be atonement for our sin.
And that leads us to point number two.
God requires justice and atonement for sin.
Let's pick back up the text verses three through six.
It says this. And David said to the gibeonites,
what shall I do for you
and how shall I make atonement
that you may bless the heritage of the Lord?
The gibeonites said to him, it is not a matter of silver
or gold between us or so in his house.
Neither is it for us to put any man to death in Israel.
And he said, well what should I do for you?
And he said to the king, the man who consumed us
and plan to destroy us so
that we should not have no place in all the
territory of Israel.
Let's seven of his sons be given to us so
that we may hang them before the Lord.
A gibb you of Saul, the chosen Lord.
And the king said, I will give them.
So they didn't want one man, they wanted seven.
This is a sobering reminder that sin man's justice
because of the breach of the treaty.
David offers to make atonement, to make right the sins
of Israel and what does it cost?
Israel more deaths.
Now I think it's important to to remember that just
because the Bible describes certain actions does not mean
that God prescribes them like it's happening here.
It may seem harsh that the nation should suffer
for the mistake of one man that is now dead.
But time does not dule God's memory or his sense of justice.
He's not just gonna forget about it. What about our nation?
Do you think the sins of our nation's leaders both past
and present will have an effect on us?
Yes. Let's bring it home a little bit.
Do you think the sins of our church leadership
of the elders both past
and present will have an effect on us?
Yes. But so does your sin and so do my sin.
No matter how long you think you've gotten away with it,
God's memory does not fade.
David responded to their requests by giving them,
which is another reminder that sin still sings
The sins of Saul cost his family their lives.
It is a well-known quote
that sin will take you further than you want to go,
keep you longer than you want to stay
and cost you more than you want to pay.
That is the nature of sin.
One can never calculate its fallout.
Sometimes like here, our sin has consequences
that abide long after the sin is committed.
The good news, 'cause there's promises that always follow.
The good news is that in the midst of the fallout,
sin does not have a final word in our lives.
If you are a believer of Christ, the consequences
of your sin do not determine your eternal destiny.
But they may affect your days.
Now friend, if you've been here before
or you've been a part of a Bible believing church
before you've heard this, this isn't new.
But God requires justice and atonement for sin.
But he provides that for us.
He provides the gospel truth
because Jesus took that justice upon himself.
Like in verse or point number one,
we talked about the gospel and
and point number two, we're talking about the gospel.
Point number three, we're gonna talk about the gospel.
God's holiness demands payment for sin
and Christ paid it all on the cross for us.
So those sins that you have that you've hidden
or that you've exposed, Christ has paid for them.
The Bible tells us to call to action is to confess those.
If we look back at our text verses seven through 14 describe
how David atone for the sins of Israel.
And verse 14 ends with this phrase, God responded
to the please of the Lord of the land.
What does this mean? Chapter 24, verse 25 says,
the Lord responded to the please of the land
and the plague was averted from Israel.
Point number three, finally we see that David, ain't it?
So I got my my physics teachers.
Now my English teachers, David ain't it,
David was not the promised king that they,
that the Israelites had put their hope in.
Read with me. Verses 15 through 20
it says there was war again between the Philistines
and Israel and David went down together with the servants
and they fought against the Philistines and David grew weary
and ish Bab, one of the descendants of the giants
who spear weighed 300 shekels of bronze
and whose armed with a new sword thought to kill David.
But Abishai the senator, Zeriah came to his aid
and attacked the Philistines
and killed him then David's being swore to him,
you shall no longer go out with us
to battle lest you quench the lamp of Israel 18.
And there was war again with the Philistines at God.
Then the Tite struck down the Saf, who is one
of the descendants of the giants 19.
And there was war again with the Philistines at Gob.
And Neil Hannon, the son of Jerry
or the Bethlehemite, struck down Goliath, the Tite,
the shaft of who spear was like a weaver's beam.
20. And there was war again at Gath where there was a man
of great stature who had six fingers on each hand,
six toes on each foot, 24 in number,
and was also a descendant from the giants.
Anyone else? When you read that, think of the movie,
the Princess Bride and the six fingered man.
Thank you. Um, but there was war again. There was war again.
There was war again. There was war again.
Four times it's mentioned.
And why, to remind us that David was not the savior.
Israel needed. The giants returned,
the wars continued, the kingdom was fractured.
David grew weary
and Israel still longed for the perfect king.
We know that that king did come
and his name was the son of David, Jesus Christ, who brought
a kingdom that would never end.
And he's gonna come again soon.
We're not too far away from advent
where we celebrate the birth, his birth
and we worship the King Mark one, 14
and 15 tells us that, that Jesus brings
God's kingdom and fullness of time.
It says the time is fulfilled, the kingdom of God is near.
Repent and believe the good news repent
and believe the good news.
So what do we do with a passage like this?
I think there's two things. Confession and worship.
Confess because the consequences of sin still sting for you,
but also for us.
Your sin is not private.
Don't just feel bad about it, but repent of it.
Turn from it. I was able to pray with one
of our elders this week, and this was part of his prayer.
He said, Lord, as elders, we are unworthy.
We are unclean. Forgive us.
May that be our church's heartbeat.
Forgive us, father of our sin.
The second thing we ought to do in a passage like this is we
see atonement for our sin.
And we should worship because we can't have the good
news without the bad news.
And we've talked about the consequences of
how sin has separated us from God for all eternity.
We should worship because why God
sent his son Jesus to pay those consequences
so that you don't have to.
So we're gonna respond in hope
and song and thank him for the cross.
So the band's gonna come out
and we're gonna sing the song Come Thou found.
And uh, I love the line O to grace,
how great a debtor daily I'm constrained to be.
Let that grace now like a F
by my wondering heart, heart to bee.
And then it says this, it says, prone to wonder, Lord,
I feel it prone to leave the God I love.
Here's my heart. Take and seal it.
Seal it for thy courts above.
Let that verse be a confession for us as a church.
That as a church, we're prone to wonder,
we're prone to leave.
But Father, take our heart, seal it for thy courts above.
If you've never confessed your sins
and believed in Jesus, we're gonna have
some prayer partners on the side.
They would love to pray with you and alongside of you
and intercede on your behalf.
Or if you want to, to pray for a health issue
or a job opportunity, they would love to,
um, come alongside.
If you're struggling
and entangled with sin, they're available that way.
Let's stand together in sing the Song
of Confession corporately.